so exactly I want you to remember is if
I draw from the North Pole through the
South Pole and background again a bunch
of great circles grateful and they all
part through the axis of the earth can
you remember what are these great
circles called they're called you know
love you
these are core meridian of longer to do
that yes I heard
these are meridians of water choose not
to be confused with parallel of latitude
latitudes are after all parallel to each
other none of them touch each other
whereas all the meridians of longitude
they all intersect at the Google Pole
and at the South Pole
okay as you point out one of the reasons
is more importantly others it's the
Prime Meridian and it's important
because it has it has it has credit on
it right so I'm going to it is about it
is about Greenwich but rich now what I
want to think about is in the course of
24 hours the earth basically does one
full revolution
okay so Greenwich will start for example
are facing the Sun and their 24-hour
glider is moving around and it faces the
Sun again and it's the same time of the
day so if there are 24 hours is day 24
hours a day and remember the earth
therefore each one of those meridians
rotate through how many degrees over
that time 360 degrees
oh sorry where where is 360 degree what
revolution in the course of we're out so
here's what I want us to recognize right
if the 24 hours day and 360 degrees of
rotation over the course of that day
then as you move across these meridians
the time is different buying well have a
think about it okay obviously we don't
draw all the meridian on because
otherwise everything and just be coming
from the sea like you know country or
cities or anything like that so we tend
to draw them spaced out a little bit
like this there are 24 of them okay what
anchor will there be between each one of
those meridians if I've drawn 2014 15
degrees 360 divided by 24 so each one of
these meridians right which represents
an hour
one hour of time also is represented by
50 butchers account sorry 50 degrees
difference in what would you okay so at
the bird I've drawn this arrow going
from west to east right so what's the
time difference between them have I gone
be careful your language sure this is
actually quite tricky you how I want
board in time or backwards in time so if
I compare let's actually put some people
here okay so I'm going to put perfect
eight
on this radiant and person B of this
reason a person a or their clock is
further forward in time okay
because this is the way the Sun actually
sorry this is the way he actually
rotates so let's actually put some tight
numbers right if I said that this person
was at time 12 noon then this person to
the west is going to be at 11:00 in the
morning that is it which therefore means
if I have done all of these equidistant
to each other and is it another 50
degrees that way what time would have
been greatly trained 10 a.m. now given
now keep in mind everyone all the same
iridium has the same time with a few
exceptions
so under that's so it's not such an
important idea I'm gonna write them
every one of the same Berean every one
of the same iridium has the same time
it's the same with some exceptions okay
so China is one of the exceptions so
China are directed by Global Way and to
put my giveaway done Bella error can
please help be China in China is across
several meridians right
now even though it's across several
Meridian it stretches across this way
the Chinese governor says actually all
of China a single time zone okay the
entire thing and there are also so let's
put this underneath great exception
right all of China is one time then
there are also some people who are on
the same yridian but they are at
different times does anyone know where
this many happens which lenders okay so
at the moment the time of the earth that
we're facing
I'll have Greenwich I'm right what's the
longitude of Greenwich it's zero degrees
right that's where we menu from okay now
therefore if we followed this guy
followed me and a all the way east
eventually we'll get round to the
opposite side of the earth if we go 180
degrees east we're going to be opposite
I'm right but it's really officer so we
could also go the other way right we
could have gone off engineer degrees
west and we end up on the safe spot at
the back does that make sense now 180
East and 180 West are at the same spot
they're at the same spot and we
basically call that the International
Dateline now the International Dateline
is continued actually in turmoil but
some of you might get there first if
you've got computer in fact could you
all if you have already devised
somewhere that line the International
Dateline is weird and we're going to
explore this business for a bit